our other top story tonight is a case
that has just captivated the valley a
man accused of killing his girlfriend's
child hiding him in a freezer and then
holding her and her daughter captive
metro police arrested brandon toslin
last month he is charged with murdering
four-year-old mason dominguez tonight we
are hearing from tozlin's ex-girlfriend
she's also the mother of his other two
children our victoria saha is live
outside the garage where police made
that gruesome discovery with how that
woman is trying to figure out what she
might have missed in the weeks leading
up to his arrest victoria
yeah the shock in agony still hasn't
worn off for the mother of tozlin's
children it's in this northeast valley
home where they would spend the weekends
with their dad his girlfriend and her
two children
mary lee ruiz shares two children with
35 year old brandon toastland although
separated for five years she says they
did their best to co-parent i saw them
both all the time ruiz says weekly
drop-offs were quick and easy and
tozlin's girlfriend always by his side
he normally just gets out of the car
lets the kids out i can see her in the
car and the kids come and we just
the last drop off was presidents day
weekend and a moment in time she will
never forget she never gave
any inclination that she needed any type
of help or any assistance it was tuesday
february 22nd when police were called to
toslin's home an employee from an
elementary school made a frantic call to
9-1-1 saying a student gave a teacher a
note from her mom saying she was being
held against her will and did not know
what happened to her four-year-old son
while approaching the house officers
stopped tosland with his girlfriend in
the car police say she was handcuffed
inside tozland holding her phone a short
time later the little boy mason
dominguez's body was found in the
freezer in the garage i'm still in shock
i don't have any answers through an
attorney the woman revealed what she
went through she says tozlund would
threaten her with weapons lock her up
and set up surveillance cameras to watch
her every move it's just
appalling to everything that's happened
ruiz is trying to figure out how the
brandon toastland she knows is so
different than the one police say he is
he loves his kids he was really big on
like getting them books and swimming and
just wanted to just provide and be there
for them
ruiz says her kids have not shared with
her anything of what they may have seen
inside the house tozlin is expected to
be in court on april 7 for a preliminary
hearing to see if there's enough
evidence to send the case to trial
victoria zaha live local now